hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
during the infancy of the internet
possibilities felt endless
and inspired some ideas have been
realized
while others have faded into
insignificance
[Music]
the internet has completely changed the
human race but with all the good
comes some of the bad it's pretty well
known now
that corporate monopolies are taking
advantage of us over the past two
decades
our web browsing habits have turned into
a hunting ground for targeted
advertising
data harvesting and the exploitation of
users by predatory
free-to-use platforms but what if there
was a way to stop it
one of the most unlikely companies
appears to be doing just that
apple in their latest software update
apple gave the iphone the ability to
block companies from buying and selling
user data
this update from apple strikes right at
the heart of facebook's business model
zuckerberg isn't happy about this and a
battle between the two tech giants
may have just begun let's take a look
this intensifying battle between the
tech giants comes as both companies are
under the regulatory microscope
guys you are watching cold fusion tv
[Music]
even though apple has started to pivot
towards software and services
apple is primarily a hardware
manufacturer thanks to this
they've managed to avoid the allure of a
data harvesting business model
and that's not to say that they haven't
overstepped they've got a long history
of exploiting their customers in other
ways
right to repair comes to mind and also
slowing down old iphones
though with all of that being said it's
clear that user privacy has always been
a priority for apple
at a 2010 conference steve jobs made his
opinions about privacy clear
to ensure that people understand
what these apps are doing a lot of
people in the valley think we're really
old-fashioned
about this privacy means people
know what they're signing up for
in plain english and repeatedly
that's what it means i i'm an optimist i
believe people are smart
and some people want to share more data
than other people do ask them
ask them every time make them tell you
to stop asking them if they get tired of
your asking them
let them know precisely what you're
going to do with their data
[Music]
okay that's that's what we think
he imagined a world of open and honest
interactions between user platforms
where there was always a choice for the
consumer
it's clear that steve jobs saw where the
data harvesting model was heading
and tim cook plans to do something about
it i spoke in brussels
about the emergence of a data industrial
complex
as i've said before if we accept as
normal
and unavoidable that everything in our
lives can be aggregated and sold
then we lose so much more than data we
lose the freedom to be human
right now users may not know whether the
apps they use
to pass the time to check in with their
friends
may in fact be passing on information
about the photos they've taken
the people in their contact list or
location data that reflects where they
eat
sleep or pray the end result
of all of this is that you are no longer
the customer
you are the product
[Music]
in ios 14 apple introduced the app
privacy function
it allowed users to see exactly what
data was being extracted from them
this put into perspective just how much
information their favorite apps were
given access to
now with this information users could
make an informed decision
for example if a user was looking to
download a new messaging platform
they could now see a clear list of data
each app would take from them
in exchange for their services for users
of the open source messaging app
signal the only thing the app would take
would be their phone number
and that's expected for facebook
messenger users on the other hand
it would come as quite a shock to find
out that as they were happily sending
messages to their friends and family
over the years
facebook was extracting their physical
address
email address name phone number
user id device id purchase history
financial information precise location
course location
contacts photos or videos gameplay
content
search history browsing data product
interaction
advertising data crash data and
performance data
the contrast is stark and without ios 14
users would have no idea when steve jobs
emphasized the importance of choice
this is what he was talking about
although consumers have always had the
opportunity to choose which apps they
use
now they could make a complete informed
decision
in ios 14.5 apple went a step further
the company introduced a feature app
tracking transparency
and tim cook has ambitious hopes that it
would impact both the tech and
advertising industries
app tracking transparency or atp enables
users to choose
whether or not they want a specific app
to access track
and share the data that is valuable to
advertisers
each time you open up an app for the
first time a pop-up message will appear
that reads
allow this app to track your activity
across other companies apps and websites
then it's followed by an appeal from the
company themselves
informing the user why tracking is
important to the functionality of the
app
if you're a user that enjoys ads
specifically targeted towards you
you can allow that but if you prefer to
keep your information private you now
have the option to opt out of advertiser
tracking entirely
apple's senior vice president of
software engineering craig federighi
explains this further to the wall street
journal uh usually telling you that
they're going to track you with a big
blue accept button and no
no real choice at all we had to make it
a meaningful choice and we had to make
it a clear
choice and one that had effect and that
i think is in deep contrast to most of
what you see
on the internet
every iphone comes with a unique string
of numbers known as your
identifier for advertisers or idfa
this number is as you may have guessed
by the name used for tracking your
actions and movements within an app
android has a similar technique but
we're focusing on ios today
if you've ever wondered how
advertisements are so specifically
targeted towards your interests
recent web searches or downloads your
idfa is responsible
here's how it works say you've decided
to take up rock climbing as a hobby
so you download a free app that shows
you climbing gyms in your area
and tracks your progress from the moment
you open that app
it will begin harvesting your data like
location and health information
but now you need some gear so you head
to your favorite shopping app to
purchase some shoes
a harness and a chalk bag you might have
even searched for entry level products
specifically
seeing as you're just a beginner both
the shopping and rock climbing apps
will then send all the information it
has gathered to a data breaker
and the data broker will then sell this
data to your social media app of choice
between the rock climbing app the
shopping app and the information that
your social media app already knows
about you
there's a fairly specific picture being
painted about the owner of this
particular idfa number
you suddenly your social media feed is
showing advertisements for beginner rock
climbing classes
and sales on entry-level climbing
products and then
special offers from gyms in your area
begin to show up
the results of data harvesting and sale
can vary but it's important to note
that this transaction is not happening
in a strictly linear way
each of the three apps are attempting to
make money off the data that they've
just been given
or bought from the data broker in fact
almost every one of the apps on your
phone is
idfa numbers allow for an intricate
interconnected system
purpose built for data extraction and
monetization
apple's app tracking transparency stops
this
right at the beginning of the process it
does this by simply blocking an app's
access
to your idfa number this means that an
app can extract all the data at once
but without a number to assign that
information to it's almost
worthless this last fact is devastating
for facebook
mark zuckerberg is upset about this and
understandably so
facebook's entire business model is
centered around targeting advertising
and sales
which are powered by the data that app
tracking transparency
is about to cut off zuckerberg quickly
realized that the profitability of his
platform was in danger
in december of 2020 facebook took a
full-page ad in the wall street journal
with a headline reading quote
we're standing up to apple for small
businesses everywhere end quote
the ad went on to explain that while
limiting personalized advertising would
hurt big corporations
it's the small businesses that would
suffer the most a facebook
representative
also claimed that these types of
restrictions would force app developers
to start charging for their products
instead of offering them for free apple
has hit back on facebook's claims
reminding everyone that the app tracking
transparency feature does not take away
an app's ability to track its users
it simply gives them a choice in the
matter
there is no doubt that ios 14.5 would
deal
a lot of damage to platforms like
facebook and this was confirmed in
january of 2021
when facebook cfo dave wayner said that
the company is expecting to see higher
opt-out rates
and in march he confirmed that
facebook's profitability is in jeopardy
stating quote we do expect this to be an
impact to the business
and impact our growth rates
in fighting against the ab tracking
transparency feature companies like
facebook have exposed their flaws
better than any critic ever could with
every statement criticizing apple for
their move
comes as an admission of guilt an
admission that the free-to-use targeted
advertising model
can only succeed if users are denied the
right to choose
we increasingly see apple um as one of
our biggest competitors i think this is
becoming more of just
more than just a tech bro rivalry and
he's really
showing his hand and maybe singling to
investors
that this is going to be a greater
problem for profitability and top-line
sales growth one of his biggest
businesses which is
advertising in the quarters ahead so to
me he seems to be sweating sweating this
out a little bit and if you're an
investor in facebook
it's something that that i would
probably take into consideration
i have no doubt that facebook who was
negatively impacted by this update
will invent new ways to get around this
and to ensure growth
but apple does have a history of setting
trends if app tracking transparency is
received
well by the public it could just be a
matter of time before other companies
create their own version
could apple be doing all of this just to
appear better in light of legal
anti-trust cases
yes that's possible but whatever their
true motive is
i think apple has ultimately done a good
thing here and at the very least
it'll be good for their brand image but
whether this will change the course of
the internet is yet to be seen
but if 2020 has taught us anything it's
to expect
the unexpected facebook isn't going down
without a fight
zuckerberg has outlined plans to
facilitate sales directly through its
own apps
facebook shops and instagram shops both
launched last year
and will allow brands to sell directly
on facebook's own social media networks
facebook also just recorded record
revenues at 26.17 billion dollars
and they have almost 3.5 billion monthly
users across their family of apps
so it's going to be interesting to see
how apple affects them in the future
so what do you guys think let me know in
the comments section below
or head over to the discord to chat i'll
be hanging around in there for a couple
of hours after this video drops
oh and also i just started another
youtube channel
it's for the music that i produce so my
more creative side
if you're interested in that kind of
stuff go check it out
and with that we've reached the end of
the episode so thanks for watching
if you've just stumbled across this
channel feel free to subscribe
otherwise you can follow me on my other
social media in the links below
my name is tagogo and you'll be watching
cold fusion
and i'll catch you again soon for the
next one cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
you